[Music]
it's often distressing to hear about the
death of a famous actor
their passings can evoke the feeling of
an end to an era
as once vital charismatic performers
head offstage for good after a final bow
these actors made us laugh made us cry
and made us feel
and many of them seem like they're gone
too soon let's remember some of the
actors that we've lost in 2018
vern troyer verne troyer best known as
the actor who plays mini-me in the
austin powers movies
died of alcohol poisoning on april 21st
at the age of 49.
troyer who stood at two feet eight
inches was born with achontroplasia
dwarfism
a condition that often results in
undersized arms and legs
he grew up in an amish community in
michigan and achieved fame when he
debuted opposite mike myers
in 1999's austin powers the spy who
shagged me
troyer had more than 50 acting credits
to his name
with roles including grip hook and harry
potter and the sorcerer's stone
and coach punch cherkov in the love guru
a message announcing his death posted to
his facebook page said
vern was an extremely caring individual
he wanted to make everyone smile
be happy and laugh stefan carl
steffensen stephen carl steffensen an
icelandic actor best known for his role
as robbie rotten on the tv series
lazytown
died on august 21 among his friends and
family following a years-long battle
with cancer of the bile duct he was 43
years old
as an actor steffensen was most readily
identifiable with his work on the
popular children series
which aired in more than 100 countries
and on which he starred for more than 10
years
a huge portion of his notoriety came
from a popular meme that sprung from the
series based on the exuberant musical
number we are number one
[Music]
whatever its ironic roots may have been
the appreciation for stefansson grew
deeply in online mean communities over
the years
and he showed much appreciation to fans
in return
he is survived by his wife and four
children and he is forever
number one jackson odell
jackson odell an actor musician and
songwriter was found dead in his home on
june 8th according to a report by tmz
20 years old he died of an accidental
overdose of heroin and cocaine
odell began his acting career at the age
of 11 making his debut on the series
private practice
he landed his first major part in the
2011 feature
judy moody and the not bummer summer
going on to make appearances on icarly
modern family and arrested development
as an actor odell is most known to
audiences for his work on the goldbergs
where he played recurring character ari
caldwell in recent years odell's work
had pivoted toward a role as a
singer-songwriter
with several of his compositions
appearing on the soundtracks to the 2016
movie great planes
and the 2018 release forever my girl
john schnapp john schnepp a writer
director
editor and animator known for his many
contributions to adult swim programming
died on july 19th from complications
following a massive stroke
he was 51 primarily known for his work
on metalocalypse
schnepp also occasionally contributed to
that series and others as a voice actor
with his other appearances including
aqua teen hunger force and space ghost
coast to coast
he directed several documentaries
including the death of superman lives
what happened
he was also an on-camera personality for
entertainment website collider
appearing as a panelist on collider
movie talk and hosting collider heroes
anthony bourdain anthony bourdain a
writer presenter producer and performer
who helped shape the way we see
international food culture took his own
life on june 8th in france
during the production of a cnn
travelogue series parts unknown
he was 61. bourdain rose to prominence
in 2000 on the back of his best-selling
book kitchen confidential
adventures in the culinary underbelly
his unapologetic attitude and
confessional style helped endear him to
a wide audience
with the book being adapted into a
television series in 2005.
that show also called kitchen
confidential starred bradley cooper as a
bad boy chef based on bourdain himself
bourdain grew to be a charismatic
presence on the international food scene
as he began appearing on television as
the host of several shows
including a cook's tour no reservations
and the layover
his notoriety also led to winking cameo
appearances
with bourdain appearing as himself in
the 2015 film the big
short he also lent his voice to
characters inspired by him in the
animated series archer and sanjay and
craig
he was decorated with awards from the
entertainment industry for his work
earning five emmys and a peabody award
pamela gidley model turned actress
pamela gidley passed away at the age of
52 on april 16th
dying peacefully of natural causes
gidley's debut role was in the 1986
skateboarding movie thrashin in which
she appeared alongside josh
brolin and childhood friend sherilyn
fenn who would later play audrey on the
series twin peaks
early in her career gidley appeared in
the cult sci-fi movie cherry 2000
playing a life like android designed to
be the perfect mate
she went on to have her own notable role
in the 1992 twin peaks prequel feature
fire walk with me
appearing as the first victim of the
killer who would later haunt the series
she also had a regular role on the buddy
cop series angel street
and starred in the mystery series
strange luck with later roles including
work on the pretender
csi and skin her last credited role
is twin peaks the missing pieces a long
lost compilation of extended and deleted
scenes from fire walk with me
mickey jones mickey jones a musician and
character actor known for his roles in
home improvement and justified
died on february 7th at the age of 76.
jones worked as an entertainer since his
teenage years working as a drummer with
the likes of trini lopez
bob dylan and kenny rogers in the first
edition he began pivoting to an acting
career in the late
60s by 1976 jones was a full-time actor
and went on to appear in a number of tv
shows and movies
including the rockford files charlie's
angels the dukes of hazzard
and the incredible hulk jones regular
role on home improvement as construction
worker pete bilker made use of both of
his talents
with the character playing the drums in
the company band he also had a recurring
role in justified
playing marijuana distributor rodney
hotrod dunham his film roles include
tin cup total recall and slingblade in
which he also put his drumming talents
to use
his final roles include the nbc comedy
series growing up fisher and a 2015
appearance in the adult swim comedy news
readers
leon white professional wrestler leon
allen white
better known as vader died on june 18th
from complications from pneumonia after
a years-long battle with congestive
heart failure
he was 63 also known as baby bull and
big van vader
white rose to prominence in wrestling
during the early 90s
coming into his own as a formidable heel
who entered rings with a distinctive and
imposing dark helmet
like many wrestlers white occasionally
took his charismatic performing talents
to more mainstream productions
appearing in episodes of baywatch and
boy meets world his character also
appeared in a wcw themed comic book
series published by marvel comics
in november 2016 white was diagnosed
with congestive heart failure and given
less than two years to live
he faced the development as only a
professional wrestler would
selling t-shirts with slogans such as
big vader just won't die
and two years to live my ass he is
survived by two children
including the second generation
professional wrestler jesse white
who is also known by the stage name of
jake carter
stanley anderson stage and screen actor
stanley anderson died on june 24th at
his home in santa rosa california at the
age of 78
six weeks after receiving a diagnosis of
brain cancer
anderson was born in 1939 in billings
montana while he would go on to leave
his mark on a number of tv shows and
movies
he didn't segue into on-screen work
until he was already a practice veteran
of the stage
his career on screen began in the 1990s
with appearances on such series as the
drew carey show the practice and nypd
blue
among his more notable performances was
his role as the judge in the widely seen
series finale of seinfeld
and as an early adversary of the green
goblin in the sam
raimi directed spider-man in addition to
his work as a performer
anderson was also a voice over talent
reading scripts for documentaries on
national geographic
discovery tlc pbs and the history
channel
he also lent his voice to nationwide
advertisements for democratic party
candidates and causes
according to his family quote he was
most proud ultimately
of the party played in politics robert
manden robert manden an actor who held a
consistent presence on television for
more than four decades
died on april 29th in los angeles
following a long period of illness
he was 86 years old born in missouri in
1932
mandan appeared on a number of soap
operas throughout his career
such as general hospital santa barbara
and days of our lives
but his most acclaimed role was on the
parody sitcom soap
which ran from 1977 to 1981. beyond soap
mandan appeared on the sitcom three's
company continuing on to that show's
1984 spin-off three's a crowd
his other notable television roles
included turns on married with children
sanford and son and star trek deep space
nine among many many more over a long
and robust career
eunice gayson eunice gayson who helped
establish a cinematic tradition as the
first bond girl of the james bond film
series
died on june 8th at the age of 90.
gayson's most well-known role remains
her turn as sylvia trench in dr no
and from russia with love from which she
became connected to one of the all-time
classic lines in cinema introducing
herself as trench
sylvia trench her character prompted the
immortal introduction of sean connery's
mi6 agent
bond james bond her performance as a
capable foil for bond established a
template for the movies that's still in
use today
after her turn in the bond series gayson
continued to act on screen until 1972
after which she exclusively performed on
stage she is survived by a daughter
kate who followed up on her mother's
james bond legacy with an appearance in
the 1995 film
goldeneye if you or anyone you know is
having suicidal thoughts
please call or chat online with the
national suicide prevention lifeline
at 1-800 that's 1-800-273-8255
if you or someone you know is struggling
with addiction please call the substance
abuse and mental health administration's
24 7 national helpline at 1-800-662-help
that number again is 1-800-662-4357